R
FALL FROM GRACE FROM BRITAIN'S
PRINCE ADDRESS THE SEXUAL ABUSE
CASE AGAINST HIM IN THE U.S. IS
ALLOWED TO PROCEED.
THIS QUEEN 2ND SON IS BEING
STRIPPED OF ALL MILITARY TITLES
AND ROYAL CHARITY ROLLS, THE
ROYAL SOURCE SAYS HE WILL ALSO
LOSE THE USE OF HIS TITLE HIS
ROYAL HIGHNESS.
THE DUKE OF YORK HELD 8
MILITARY TITLES, WHICH CAME
WITH A BIG ROLE IN THE ANNUAL
TRIPPING OF THE CALLOUS
CEREMONY.
MAX FOSTER IS HERE WITH MORE.
>> PRINCE ANDREW, THE DUKE OF
YORK, WILL NO LONGER BE CALLED
HIS ROYAL HIGHNESS, ACCORDING
TO ROYAL SOURCE.
AND ALL OF HIS MILITARY TITLES
AND ROYAL PATRONAGE'S HAVE BEEN
RETURNED TO THE QUEEN.
AND HE WON'T GET THEM BACK,
THIS HORSE SAYS.
HE IS STILL PART OF THE FAMILY,
BUT HE'S OUT OF THE FIRM.
HE WILL FOCUS INSTEAD ON
DEFENDING HIMSELF AS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN IN A U.S. YOUNG
LAWSUIT.
THESE DECISION FOLLOWED A U.S.
JUDGE'S RULING THIS WEEK THAT
THE CIVIL SEX EXCUSE CASE
AGAINST PRINCE ANDREW CAN
PROCEED.
VIRGINIA GIUFFRE SAYS SHE WAS
ONLY 17 WHEN SHE WAS TRAFFICKED
BY CONVICTED SEX OFFENDER
JEFFREY EPSTEIN TO THE ROYAL.
WHO SHE ALLEGES SEXUALLY ABUSED
HER IN 3 DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
PRINCE ANDREW DENIES
ALLEGATIONS AND SAYS HE NEVER
EVEN MET HER.
GIUFFRE'S LAWYER TOLD THE BBC,
HE DIDN'T THINK HIS CLIENT WAS
INTERESTED IN A PURELY
FINANCIAL SETTLEMENT.
A SOURCE CLOSE TO ANDREW SAYS,
QUOTE, THIS IS A MARATHON, NOT
A SPRINT, AND THE DUKE WILL
CONTINUE TO DEFEND HIMSELF
AGAINST THESE CLAIMS.
>> NOT COMFORTABLE, TO HAVE TO
SIT THERE AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
IN THIS LAWSUIT HE'S NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO EVADE AND DODGE.
HE'S GONNA HAVE TO STEP UP NOW
AND ANSWER.
>> ANDREW HAS BEEN UNDER
SCRUTINY FOR YEARS FOR HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE LATE
EPSTEIN AND HIS ASSOCIATE,
GHISLAINE MAXWELL.
THOUGH THE RELATIONSHIPS HAVE
DAMAGED HIS REPUTATION, THE
PRINCE HASN'T BEEN CHARGED WITH
ANY CRIMINAL WRONGDOING.
MAXWELL WAS ALSO FOUND GUILTY
LAST MONTH ON 5 FEDERAL JUDGES,
INCLUDING SEX TRAFFICKING OF A
MINOR.
>> WIZ NEWS FOR ABOUT 6 MONTHS
--
>> AFTER A DISASTROUS UK TV
APPEARANCE IN 2019 WHERE HE
TRIED AND FAILED TO CLEAR HIS
NAME, THE DUKE TEMPORARILY
STEPPED BACK FROM PUBLIC
DUTIES.
>> I CAN ABSOLUTELY
CATEGORICALLY TELL YOU IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> THE LAWSUIT IS ANOTHER BLOW
TO THE 95-YEAR-OLD QUEEN WHO,
IN THE PAST YEAR, HAS ENDURED
THE DEATH OF HER HUSBAND,
PRINCE PHILIP, BEING LEVELED
WITH ALLEGATION OF
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM AGAINST
THE PALACE BY HER GRANDSON,
HARRY, THE DUKE'S SUSSEX, AND
WIFE MEGHAN, IN AN INTERVIEW
WITH OPRAH WINFREY.
AT THE TIME, THE PALACE
DESCRIBED THE CLAIMS AS
CONCERNING AND SAID THEY WILL
BE DEALT WITH PRIVATELY.
WHO KNOWS HOW SHE FEELS AS A
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER ABOUT
THE FAMILIES TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS.
BUT AS A MONARCH, SHE'S KNOWN
TO PUT DUTY FIRST AND CASTING
ANDREW OUT WAS THE ONLY WAY SHE
COULD PROTECT THE FAMILY FIRM
FROM FURTHER REPUTATIONAL HARM.
MAX FOSTER, CNN, HAMPSHIRE,
ENGLAND.
>> JOINING ME NOW FROM LOS
ANGELES IS CENTRAL MENTALLY,
HE'S A TRUSTEE OF THE ROYAL
SOCIETY OF ST. GEORGE.
AND A ROYAL WATCHER FOR US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, MY FRIEND.
PRINCE UNTRUE EFFECTIVELY
STRIPPED OF ROYAL PATRONAGE'S
MILITARY COMMISSIONS, WHILE
CARRYING OUT PUBLIC APPEARANCES,
KNOW YOUR ROYAL HIGHNESS,
EFFECTIVELY A PRIVATE CITIZEN
NOW, ISN'T HE?
HOW MUCH OF A FALL HAS THIS
BEEN FOR THE QUEEN 2ND ELDEST?
>> THE DUKE'S AND DISGRACE.
YOU KNOW, 2022 WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE A GOOD YEAR FOR THE FAMILY.
COMING UP IS THE 70TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE QUEEN ON THE
THRONE.
IN STEAD, THIS YEAR'S
OVERSHADOWED BY THE PRINCE
ANDREW SCANDAL.
LOOKING AT THAT STATEMENT, IT'S
SO COLD AND STARK.
IMAGINE IF THIS HAD BEEN
HANDLED DIFFERENTLY, THE ROYAL
FAMILY COULD HAVE SAID WE LOVE
YOU AND YOU.
THEY COULD'VE WAITED TO LET THE
SYSTEM PLAY OUT AND SEE WHAT
WAS THE OUTCOME OF THE SEXES
SALT LAWSUIT.
INSTEAD, THEY ACTED SWIFTLY,
DECISIVELY, AND DECIDED THAT
ANDREW WAS SO TOXIC, HE NEEDED
TO BE THROWN OUT IN THE
GARBAGE.
>> I GUESS THE CAR'S AGAINST
HIM IS FAR FROM RESOLVED ONE
AREA OR THE OTHER, HE DENIES
THE ALLEGATIONS, BUT IT DOES
SHOW HOW EMBARRASS THE FAMILY'S,
THE FIRM BY THE REVELATIONS AND
ACCUSATIONS, EVEN UNPROVEN.
>> ABSOLUTELY, THEY WANT HIS --
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
TALKS WENT ON AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL, I'M TALKING THE BIG 3,
THE QUEEN, CHARLES, AND WILLIAM.
CLEARLY, ALL IN AGREEMENT,
PUTTING OUT THAT STATEMENT
TODAY THAT ANDREW HAS TO FIGHT
THIS CASE AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
AND PRINCE ANDREW HAS CONTINUE
TO DENY THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CLAIMS.
BUT THE ROYAL FAMILY HAS TAKEN
THE DECISION TODAY.
WE THERE'S NO WAY BACK FOR HIM.
I THINK LOSING THE MILITARY
TITLES WILL REALLY MAKE HIM
REFLECT WITH SADNESS,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THIS YEAR IS
THE 40TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FALKLAND'S WAR IN WHICH PRINCE
ANDREW SERVED AS A HELICOPTER
PILOT, AND HE WON'T BE ABLE TO
TAKE PART IN ANY OF THE
ANNIVERSARIES FOR THAT OR ANY
MORE MILITARY FUNCTIONS EVER
AGAIN.
THE ROYALS HAVE ACTED
DECISIVELY AND SWIFTLY.
>> YES WE.
AND IT DOES OVERSHADOWED THE
ONE QUEENS PLATINUM JUBILEE.
IT'S A BIG DEAL.
I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS, BECAUSE
IT'S INTERESTING, HOW MIGHT HE
FUND HIS DEFENSE OR IF THERE IS
A SETTLEMENT, HOW MIGHT HE PAY
FOR THAT IF THAT OPPORTUNITY
ARISES?
WHO PAYS THE BILL?
HIS LIFE IS LARGELY FUNDED, NOT
COMPLETELY, BUT LARGELY FUNDED
BY HIS MOTHER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE HAS ATTENTION FROM ITS
SERVICES AND KOREA.
I THINK HE GETS 323,000 A YEAR
IN SALARY.
BUT HE DEPENDS ON HIS MOTHER,
YES.
WILL THE QUEEN PAY THE BILLS?
WILL PRINCE ANDREW DECIDED TO
GO ALL THE WAY AND TAKE THIS TO
COURT AND SEEK TO CLEAR HIS
NAME?
I KNOW YOU SAY HOPEFULLY IT
WON'T OVERSHADOW THE JUBILEE.
IT WILL.
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE MAIN
STORY OF THE YEAR, WE'LL SEE
HOW THIS PLAYS OUT.
>> WE GOOD POINT, I GUESS --
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WITH
PRINCE ANDREW, WHAT IS ALL OF
THIS SAY ABOUT HIS JUDGMENT
ABOUT HIS FRIENDS, GHISLAINE
MAXWELL, EPSTEIN, PRETTY POOR
JUDGMENT.
>> WE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF POOR
JUDGMENT WAS WHEN HE GAVE HIS
TV INTERVIEW WITH THE BBC TO
DEFEND HIMSELF.
ONE OF THE MOST INEPT PR
EXERCISES OF ALL-TIME.
AND THAT ONLY SERVE TO
INCRIMINATE HIM IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION.
PUBLIC OPINION TURNED AGAINST
PRINCE ANDREW AT THE TIME.
SO, YES, AT THE TIME, HE HASN'T
DONE MUCH TO HELP HIMSELF.
AND THE ROYAL FAMILY HAVE
CLEARLY SAID, OKAY, WE'VE HAD
IT WITH YOU.
YOU ARE OUT ON YOUR OWN.
DON'T GET US INVOLVED IN THIS
SCANDAL.
HE'S REPEATEDLY MADE BAD
JUDGMENTS.
SO, IF HE'S --
WHATEVER HE'S GUILTY OF, HE'S
DEFINITELY 100% GUILTY OF BAD
JUDGMENT, BAD CHOICES, AND
TERRIBLE PR.
>> EVEN IF NOTHING HUGE COMES
OUT OF THESE ALLEGATIONS, DO
YOU THINK THERE'S ANY WAY BACK
FOR HIM IN TERMS OF A ROYAL
ROLE?
>> ZERO.
HE'S FINISHED.
WE WILL NEVER SEE HIM AGAIN ON
THE BALCONY WITH THE QUEEN.
THERE'S NO WAY BACK.
PERSONALLY, I CANNOT SEE IT.
WE WILL BE DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE
THE ROYAL FAMILY WELCOMING HIM
BACK.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE, BUT I
WOULDN'T PUT THE HOUSE ON IT.